welcome back today we're going to talk
about the thyroid
i have some interesting information i'm
going to try to keep this really really
simple
if you have a thyroid problem this video
is for you
i've done a lot of videos in the past on
the thyroid
this one comes in at a slightly
different angle okay
so we have two different situations with
the thyroid we have
a thyroid condition we have not enough
hormones it's called a hypothyroidism
and then a condition where you have too
many hormones that's called a
hyper thyroidism okay
now with a hypo 90
of the time it's going to be hashimoto's
that's an autoimmune issue
with a hyper thyroid issue
80 of the time it's going to also be an
autoimmune condition
called graves disease okay so that's the
first thing you need to know
um most of these conditions are
autoimmune conditions so they're really
not thyroid as much as their immune
issues and so let's just kind of go
through this
with a hypo okay not enough thyroid
hormones
and we're talking primarily about
hashimoto's
it occurs eight times more in women now
with a hyper graves um you also see
almost eight it's like 7.5 times more
common women between the ages of 40 and
60. okay so that's the first
clue another clue is that one of the
triggers for a hypo
hashimoto's is that a woman who gives
birth
in three to eight months postpartum past
their
their birth has higher incidence
of hashimoto's so what does that tell us
right there
estrogen is involved and we already know
that estrogen blocks the conversion
from t4 to t3 now if we switch over to
graves
there's a seven times higher risk of
developing this condition
a year following your delivery
again involving estrogen so estrogen
apparently is a big
trigger when you get a a total t4 and a
total
t3 measured on your blood test
that is not the best test you should get
a free
t4 and a free t3 test
you're going to have more accurate data
now when we talk about tsh
thyroid stimulating hormone okay which
by the way
that is not a thyroid hormone it's a
pituitary
hormone your pituitary makes a lot of
different hormones
and that's one of them it controls the
thyroid from above
from somewhere in your brain a lot of
doctors will use
the normal value of 0.4 to 5
as being normal but there's some more
credible data
that states that that normal value for
thyroid stimulating hormone should be
0.45
to 2.5 okay not all the way up to 5.
that would be a more of a normal range
that i would focus on so if it's above
that
then there's a problem and also realize
that the higher the
tsh goes now the next point i want to
bring up is
the relationship between t4 and t3 t4 is
a pre
thyroid hormone and then t3 is the
active thyroid hormone
so it has to be converted and there's a
huge
problem with a lot of people with the
conversion
and so you need certain things to help
you convert which we'll get into in a
second
but if you have a thyroid problem and
you're on synthroid you're taking t4
realize you're taking the inactive
version your body has to convert it
and what you may not realize is that 20
percent
of t3 is produced directly from your
thyroid gland
and the rest is the t4 so if you're
given
t4 only and not t3
you could be a bit shy on getting the
full
benefit of the thyroid hormones thus the
reason why you still have these symptoms
and the other reason why you may have
still have symptoms and you're on
synthroid is just simply because they're
treating
a secondary problem or you have a
problem with the conversions
so what would you do if you have a
hype o hashimoto situation here's some
ideas i would recommend taking selenium
zinc both of these help the conversion
from t4 to t3 they're also very powerful
antioxidants
and the inflammation that's generated
from these autoimmune conditions
block the conversion these cytokines
block this conversion
so this these two will help reduce that
inflammation and help the convergence
now vitamin d is just a given
vitamin d helps autoimmune conditions in
general and it's going to
lower the inflammation seek help would
be beneficial
not just with the iodine but it also has
selenium and zinc and
a lot of the other trace minerals and
then purify bile salts
bile salts help convert t4 to t3
and so they will increase more thyroid
hormone production
and if you have a liver problem a fatty
liver
a gallbladder problem thickened bile
you're going to be deficient in bile
salts and that could be the reason why
you're not converting thyroid hormones
now let's shift over to graves vitamin d
is essential i would recommend if you're
going to take vitamin d for
any autoimmune issue it should be
minimally
fifteen thousand ius twenty thousand i
use
up to forty thousand i use or even more
and the next thing i'm gonna recommend
is vitamin b1
why because b1 can lower
your estrogen dominance if you have a
hyperthyroid condition
one of the things that happens is you
use a lot of b1 and so
you're usually going to be very
deficient and you're also going to be
deficient vitamin d but you're going to
be really deficient in b1
and if you're deficient in b1 you can
have a lot of the symptoms that will
mimic
a lot of other conditions so you want to
take bottom b1
in fact i would probably take it with
the hypo as well
but for hyper cases like graves you
don't want to take purify bile salts
because
that's going to give you more thyroid
hormones it's going to help you convert
more
you already have too much so you don't
want to take that
all right so that's all i wanted to
communicate about the thyroid in this
video thanks for watching before you go
if you have a question about a product
or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on keto
and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help
you